all right now we're recording so welcome
again everyone who is here live and
thank you for those of you now watching
maybe in a recorded version later today
is st. Patrick's Day and I am not
wearing green I did not succeed enough
in that area today but I do have a nice
little Irish restaurant and pub down the
street and we're planning to do a
drive-through for corned beef for my
husband and kids and fish and chips for
me so I am looking forward to that so
well maybe we'll bring it home all the
restaurants are closed for eat in but
we're allowed to drive by and get that
so I figured that'd be a nice treat for
us and for me for not cooking tonight so
happy st. Patrick's Day everyone if you
celebrate or it's kind of one of those
holidays I think everyone celebrates at
least in some small form today the
webinar is called jumping ship
strategies for a successful career
transition I feel like this is a common
conversation that I have with a lot of
Udacity students because the reason
oftentimes you're taking a Udacity
course and taking learning new
technology is because you'd like to have
a career transition sometimes that can
be from something maybe a small pivot
from one area of software development to
something just a little bit different
sometimes it can be a lot more drastic
either way I think what I've tried to do
is outline a process and a thinking a
way for you to think about the
transition and approach it to have the
most success as you go through this I
also think that because there are a lot
of you going through this I hope it you
can talk share your strategies give some
input I've done a lot of research
through other sources as well as other
coaches also talking to so many students
every day and finding out what I think
makes people the most successful
if you haven't met me yet I'm Angela
McDonald I'm one of the career coaches
here I've been with Udacity working for
about a year I also do a lot of
corporate training typically all that
corporate training the in-person has
been canceled at least for the next
month or two so in that case I will be
doing more coaching so you can look from
where at times opening up as
unfortunately other things get cancelled
but good for all of you I have a
background in finance talk about a
career transition right I was working in
banking the early part of my career
shifted into some international business
I lived in China Australia and Singapore
and then I found myself working into
corporate training and career coaching I
especially loved presentation skills
training that's probably my favorite so
if you ever have any questions about
presentation skills communication skills
they're team building I can also help
you with those so I have a few quotes to
start us off today and instead of
hearing my voice who would like to
unmute themselves and read this quote
especially if maybe you know who this is
I am NOT the biggest sports fanatic out
there but I do know this particular name
so who can unmute themselves and read
this book for us anyone anyone marina I
might pick on you because we've talked
and I know your name but maybe people
aren't all in a situation where they can
unmute so I'll give a couple seconds if
anyone wants to jump in Oh
any takers
all right I can read people think I'm
hearing anyone else but I'm going if
you're able to unmute later you know
maybe I have a setting that's not
allowing you to let me just check that
oh there's an Orion can we hear you
Noreen I think okay can I hear you oh I
didn't hear you Murray I'm not sure
sorry we can see you hello but I can't
hear you so I'll read this one you miss
100% of the shots you never take Wayne
Gretzky who knows what sport he played
I'm started all of you do I'm usually
the one that does not answer the sports
trivia but he was hockey player oh I
think I hear you know e now oh really
yes I hear you I'll let you read the
next one I have another one coming up
okay yes and I really think this is you
know just a great one to remember you
miss 100% of the shots you never take
that means we need to take some risks we
need to put ourselves out there and not
be afraid to speak up and show up so how
about Noreen let's see if you can get
our next one for us a longer one for you
in a chronically leaking boat energy
devoted to changing vessels is more
productive than energy to be lost
Marines fabio again
this one's from Warren Buffett who we
all know and a chronically leaking boat
energy devoted to changing vessels is
more productive than energy devoted to
patching leaks so I'm gonna explain this
one a little especially maybe if
someone's we've got some non-native
English speakers maybe this is one's a
little bit longer to think about but if
we think about that you're in a boat
that's leaking and if you're gonna think
I'm gonna patch this when it I'm gonna
fix this I'm gonna fix this or what if
it's just better to get in figure out a
way to get into a new boat that's
working or a new boat that's over on the
other side of the island and if you
think about that from a career
standpoint if you're in a in a job and
in an industry in a career that you're
thinking is okay you've not super-happy
but you just keep trying to tweak things
to me
get a little better but maybe it's time
to make that bigger transition when
saying you know over here on this career
path I'm just it's gonna be a lot more
productive in the long run the next one
sheryl sandberg from face book we cannot
change what we are not aware of and once
we are aware we could not help but
change so in this and one of the things
we'll do today is go through a
self-assessment to help you think about
building that self-awareness those the
strengths that you bring the
transferable skills you can bring and
making sure that we're really aware of
those to help position you into that
next role that you want and our last
quote up there is from Steve Jobs I've
always had wonderful things and great
advice the only way to do great work is
to do it is to love what you do if you
haven't found that yet keep looking and
don't settle so again I hear a lot of
people when they think about maybe going
back to work after a break or changing
careers and they feel like oh it's too
late I don't have the time I'll just
I'll be fine this is good enough and
really I think that when we look at the
bigger picture and we open the
opportunities for ourselves and think
you know what I'm really gonna go out
there and do what I love and we'll be a
lot happier so those are some
inspirational quotes to get us started
and now a little agenda but we are going
to cover in the next hour so actually
not the attendee yet how about I'd like
to know those of you thinking about your
personal transition so again I said you
know earlier if I had been doing this
many years ago I would have said I'm
transitioning from finance into
corporate training so I went from a very
analytical finance major credit analyst
type of work into the training and
leadership development over time so
finish this sentence for us again you
can type it or you can speak up but tell
us you are transitioning from what to
what give us
I've talked to someone yesterday okay
we've got a software engineer to product
manager very good I think we talked I
can't tell your full name
it says ad hitha I think we've talked
recently haven't we that name sounds
familiar that I saw in an email
I am transitioning from finance program
manager to data science very good does
anyone else want to share
got one from Jean and someone said
petroleum from petroleum engineering to
development from a stay-at-home parent
volunteer to software engineer also
software engineering and a closing
department to software engineering and
an on closing department very good
transitioning from a manager to software
engineer from a singer to software
developer singer as in actually a singer
I was really impressed don't lose those
skills either that's a fun hobby even if
you don't do it professionally anymore
it couldn't was that Gina read off
someone wanting to say something we've
got network engineer to machine learning
engineer financial accountant Account
Manager to data analyst excellent thank
you all for sharing so it's good to know
where some of us are coming from and
going to and sometimes you know people
we start thinking about a transition but
we haven't laid it out they're saying
I'm going I'm a network engineer now and
I'm going to be a machine learning
engineer really believing it and putting
it out there putting it in writing and
starting to to develop the how you're
going to do it and the first step is
sometimes getting it writing and saying
it you know I'm going to go from being a
stay-at-home parent to being a software
engineer again that's what's gonna
happen and sometimes that those positive
Reformation czar really good for us so
what we're gonna cover today first
making up beginning with the end in mind
we're gonna talk about researching
target jobs I'm gonna help you complete
a self-assessment looking at your
strengths your gaps and your
transferable skills we're going to talk
about learning the landscape of this new
area that you're transitioning into
we're gonna talk about creating your
narrative and then talk about some of
the next steps that you might want to
think about after this so we want to
start
destination we want to begin with the
end in mind this is a thing that's come
through and a lot of Stephen Covey's
books especially the 7 Habits of Highly
Effective People and again one more
quote for us today to share is to begin
with the end in mind folks I am sorry
I'm trying to move things around too
much I'm gonna to begin with the end in
mind means to start with a clear
understanding of your destination it
means to know where you're going so you
have a better understanding where you
are now so the steps you take are always
in the right direction so you know it's
like having that action plan and imagine
your GPS if you never told it where
you're trying to get to it's gonna have
a really hard time telling you which way
to turn so beginning with that end in
mind and just like you all said you know
that that position you want to
transition to that's that's your end
goal and a lot of people with their
career coaching sessions they're taking
a lot of classes they're building these
skills and I say well what do you want
to do next and they're not really sure
and that's that's okay to not be a
hundred percent sure you know there are
times in our lives where maybe we're not
quite sure but at some point when you
really want to start making that
transition moving into a new role you
need to to have that end goal in mind
can it change absolutely but getting
some focus is it's a lot easier to to be
on a job search and to feel some
momentum when you have that end in mind
so what does it mean again it know you
know the job you are targeting so is it
the ultimate dream job that you're gonna
it's gonna satisfy you for life
absolutely not it can be a stepping
stone can be the next step on the
journey and it could be flexible
remember targets move so if you're
thinking of being a data analyst maybe
on your path there it takes a couple
little turns and you do something a
little similar for awhile then become a
data analyst or your junior data analyst
and then you have a goal within a few
years to become more of a senior data
analyst so allow it
be flexible but keep some of that focus
it helps you a lot in the transition
so I always recommend that people select
a few of these when we think of this
dream job this destination and again not
dream as and dream ultimate but this
next job this next position that we'd
like you want to do some research find
that those ideal positions what do they
look like search job boards for keywords
and job titles sometimes avoid just the
job title that's right don't avoid it
but in addition to if you just say I
want to be a data analyst and you just
search for those kinds of jobs sometimes
you might be missing other things that
are out there that might have a similar
title company might call it something a
little bit different so sometimes then
switching over to some keywords
analytics data searching by keywords can
pull up some different titles that might
also interest you so that's one way to
search for these jobs another way I
really like to do it is search LinkedIn
for people who have the job title that
you want so when I was moving back to
America several years ago and I knew I
wanted to work in corporate training and
career coaching but I wanted to start
finding out what that looked like in
Chicago I was had been in Asia for 16
years and most recently then I had been
in Singapore so I knew you know the the
landscape that we're gonna talk about is
gonna look a lot different so I went
onto LinkedIn and I search people for
the title that I wanted so that I could
see okay where are they working where if
they worked in the past a lot of people
and in my particular situation have
their own businesses but at some point
they worked somewhere else or they or
they contract with other companies so as
your if you're living in I forget some
of the cities and states people say
let's just say you are in Ames Iowa I
just read a book in this where it was
taking place so let's say your name is
Iowa and you know you want to be a data
analyst look look on LinkedIn and type
in data analyst look in Ames Iowa see
where all of those people work a lot of
times you'll see some you'll start to
pick up on some companies that must have
really robust data science departments
the
you're seeing a lot of people with that
title or similar titles and that's a
good way to a find out what those
positions look like where those people
work and then go in to those companies
that makes a great list for some target
companies for you and then it also lets
you kind of explain look back so if you
find someone that maybe their titles a
little too senior look at where they
worked previously look at their past
couple positions what's been their
transition how did they get there and
that's gonna give you some good ideas on
job titles and companies to look at then
the next thing is to explore job
openings with your dream company I have
a lot of people that I talk to say I'll
say well what is that dream job what are
you really looking for and they'll say
well I'd really love to work for Amazon
but you know that would be really hard
so what I'm gonna do is bah-bah-bah and
I say well at least look right and I've
had people OTT of people have a lot of
success than getting the job with that
dream company if you have the luxury of
time especially and you know these are
the top five companies you really really
love to work for then start your job
search by really focusing on just those
companies and now if you said I really
need a job next week and and things are
tough and I've got to get a job as fast
as I can but that probably wouldn't be
my best strategy or advice to give you
so in terms of that if you have a little
bit of time if you have that luxury that
you have some time to expand your search
start with what you really really really
want sometimes I think we're afraid to
go for that thing that we know we love
and we go for something it feels safer
so spend some time focus on those those
dream companies and then you know start
to expand the search as you maybe
exhaust those resources or not finding
enough openings I feel like you you're
up on they're hiring in the jobs that
they're listing and then you expand from
there but start your search bit really
focused on what you know you love and
what if you know that
so the next thing is to research some
job descriptions so if we look back at
that last slide we see that this is
where we're gonna do the REIT we're
gonna find these job titles these job
descriptions and we're gonna start
getting a list of what these titles look
like what the companies are and then I
want you to really as you look through
these job descriptions I want you to ask
yourself these three questions am i
confident I can do the job do I need
about 75% of the requirements and what
do I like about it do I like it and as
you're if the job search can be very
overwhelming and if at the first screen
of a job description and I know I work
with a lot of very analytical people and
they like to read through every point in
the job description and really
understand every little thing and what
if this and what if that and I don't
know why you would be suited for this I
want you to not be so detailed in this
first scan I want you to read it huh
yeah I think I can do that I think I
made about 70 percent requirements what
I like about it I think I would really
enjoy that company and I think that
would be a great place to work okay that
goes in the to look at closer pile now
if I look at it and go oh I could
totally do this job but I'm way
overqualified I'm gonna take it out or
yeah I could do this job
oh they want to help me to have a PhD
not sure I'm gonna meet those
requirements and that looks like it's
pretty high on their list so I think
I'll kick that one out so do that quick
screening scan it just like someone's
gonna scan your resume really quickly
and get those quick points do enough
that you can say am i confident I can do
the job doing meat about 75% of the
requirements and what do I like about it
you want to like that job so that's kind
of the
doing that that research into these job
descriptions another thing I often
recommend to at this stage is to if
you're if you're coming up with a lot of
job descriptions here's looking at a lot
you're reading through them start figure
out what does that ideal job look like
to you and then you can start putting
together this job description but is you
know instead of just saying I want to be
a machine learning engineer maybe you
start having some more criteria and you
start outlining what it is you really
want that job to look like so you have
even stronger focus
okay then we're gonna do a job
assessment we're gonna look now if we
figure it out like okay I want to be a
machine learning engineer these are the
10 or 12 jobs out there that I've really
liked now I've got to really assess what
this job looks like and the first thing
most of you all in fact what are the top
technical skills required because
remember I said you only need to meet
about 75% of their requirements but we
want those 75% if they're what your
meeting needs to be those the top
especially technical skills they're
looking for so if it's the number one
most important skill they need is
advanced Python skills and that's the
one skill you don't have then it's
probably not a good match so think about
those top technical skills required and
really make sure you have a grasp on
what they're looking for and if your if
your skill level matches that job and
then start thinking about what are the
top soft skills required and you know do
you collaborate with a lot with the
teams you have a lot of decision-making
are you managing projects think about
things outside of just you know I've had
people go in and they can they can code
the heck out of something and they pass
that coding assessment but the soft
skills the communication the ability to
kind of do that data storytelling
describing their work is sometimes where
they fall short sometimes people are the
opposite so we want to assess both of
those and I want you to really think
again what attracts me to this role why
do I like it this is all part of this
kind of going through this job
assessment self-assessment making sure
we're targeting the right types of jobs
so we're building skills in the right
direction
so that you know you don't want to be
trying to build skills over here and
then take a path that's going in the
other direction and then suddenly you're
like wait I don't feel qualified because
these are actually the jobs I want are
very different so this is all about like
aligning the jobs that are out there the
skills they're looking for with what you
want what you like to do
you
questions at this stage please feel free
again to speak up to type give you a
second to think about it type this in
the chat at any point please
so we've analyzed the jobs we've
researched what's out there we we have a
pretty clear picture of where we're
headed what we're looking for now we
need to do that self assessment and this
is really important and it is there's a
lot more thinking and strategic in-depth
look at ourselves that we can take then
most people often do when they first
jump into the job search and I want you
to think about what are your strengths
what are your weaknesses our gaps and
what are your transferable skills and
again while thinking about these three
things I want you to be thinking it with
that job in mind so it's almost like
okay this is the job that I want so I'll
get the job over here and the other one
is my assessment how
those lining up how are those fitting
together okay so I'm gonna just pause
here for a second there are a few
questions popping up and she'd be
thinking about these that I'm gonna
we're going to talk about how to walk
through each one
someone said do you write all of this
information to later review with a coach
Jean that's a great question if the more
work you do on your own and then and
help share with the coach the more we
can even help you the more we can help
you so that's a great thought I've had
people come to me and say you know I put
together kind of this dream role what it
looks like based on my research these
are the areas I think I have the
strength can you help me like let's look
at the transferable skills I'm not
really sure how I can communicate that
we can go through that in a lot more
detail
or it might all be in your head and you
want to talk about it and that's okay
too
some people like to be a lot more
detailed and some people like to just
talk through it and either way is fine
whatever works for you someone said
would you add advanced but irrelevant
education to your resume when applying
especially for an entry-level position
if it is so you said Advanced Education
so that makes me think absolutely yes I
think that when we see someone's whole
profile I've had people say oh I took
out that job that was eight years
because it wasn't relevant and I said
well then it makes me look like you were
sitting on their couch for eight years
and like if you were actually working
and had value there let's put it in
there right and it also gives you more
stories and enrichment to talk about and
then what often comes up an interview if
you're talking about with getting to
know them and then you're like oh
actually I took a class in blah blah
blah oh why isn't that on your resume so
I always feel like get it all out there
work experience education get it all out
there especially if it's more advanced
education now where we might want to
scale down on the details is probably on
things that aren't as relevant so let's
say you worked in a completely unrelated
industry for ten years I'll use an
example of someone that was very
involved in nonprofits and arts and did
a lot of content creation and she was
shifting into something a bit different
so we just like took that kind of 10-15
years of her experience and pulled it
down to a a point that said it's
something like various experience in the
arts and nonprofits and had the years
and a couple bullet points in there so
it kind of took like these jobs that
were over ten years and just summarized
it down into one chunk and that really
worked well for her same with education
you can kind of lump some things
together they say continuing education
in let's say it was and somebody give me
a topic maybe it was in like net
working and not our network more
hardware and not software but you're
moving into but kind of lumping that
together too so that's like that's a lot
of knowledge that you come with and
there's some transferable skills that
can be in there so I you know if you
took a keyboarding class you don't need
to put that in but if you've taken some
really advanced technical classes you
know scale it down if it's not as
relevant so that you've room to bulk up
what is more relevant Oh Jean said in
the
I can see a person is completing a
document let me go back and see maybe I
just picked a picture that looked like
and I will get to kind of this
self-assessment in a second so strengths
I think are pretty obvious we you know
we want to really obviously look at
those technical skills and soft skills
think about yourself if you're if you
feel like you have a hard time answering
some of these questions think what would
my colleagues say what would my manager
say well what if I was gonna pick myself
fur to be on a team why would someone
want me on that team and think about
what do you really bring what are your
strengths if you want more kind of data
on that you could also do some different
personality assessments disk is a really
good one that's quite simple so it
doesn't take like a trained psychologist
help you understand everything that you
get from it a lot of the coaches have
worked with disk and we can help you if
you do an assessment myers-briggs is a
big one there's others like Hogan that
are much more in-depth personally I
think for career coaching and coaching
assessments disk is something you can
tackle really quickly to understand a
little bit more of your personality if
you're kind of looking for that in terms
of your strengths and we can talk about
that in another session weaknesses and
gaps we don't want to ignore these right
so we want to look through those job
descriptions and say oh like I'm awesome
at Python and that'll be no problem but
they also want me to know something in
sensor fusion which I haven't worked
with much so I need to figure out how
important that weaknesses should I take
a class should I not worry about it too
much because the job really is focusing
on other things I think one of the
problems with job descriptions and I've
heard this from many recruiters is if
I'm recruiting from a certain let's say
computer vision engineer and I talk to
the eight managers who need similar
people these eight managers tell me
eight different things that they would
like so I kind of have to
a lot of that in there so then it's this
like human plea that can come out of
nowhere so that's right some people
don't get too caught up in all of those
details there sometimes they are a
nice-to-have not a must-have even if
it's in the required section I'm gonna
address one of the questions I have a
PhD in economics I've had people tell me
I'm not what they're looking for for a
new grand position or internship because
of this but it's hard to gain experience
from these entry-level positions to
break into the industry Daniel that's a
really good point and I will say I've
got a really great article that I'd like
to share with you I'm gonna give you my
I'm gonna type my email in here now and
if you can email me later I'm gonna
share it with you it's about
transitioning from academia into
industry and some of the challenges that
come along with it and I have worked
with a lot of Udacity students have been
in this situation and a lot of it is
showing your relevance to industry and
showing your interest and that you that
you're capable to think from those
perspectives and make that transition
and then obviously the new grad
positions they're gonna think you're
coming with too much knowledge and
probably too much of a paycheck
so we want to help you find a better
position yourself I think my
there now so she can email me I will
send you that article might be the best
way to get it to you all right so
about transferable skills because I have
a lot of people say to me oh I don't
think I have any of those this job is
completely different there's a
transferable skill in anything you've
ever done I think sometimes too the days
in college when I was waiting tables at
a restaurant there are things that I
learned in communicating with people
then but I can still use today there are
so many things that I did in banking
when I learned about managing projects
and dealing with people that I use today
so it's just a matter of every what I
put here is a list of ten of the top
transferable skills like we imagine
these all those different buckets and
you think through your different work
experience your different life
experiences your projects if you are in
academia PhD you've done a ton of
research how did you tackle those
problems organize those so let's just
kind of go down this list and think
about the different types of
transferable skills - it's really it's
kind of to get your wheel spinning and
think about how you can extract some of
those transferable skills from your past
so you can talk about it and positioning
yourself for this new role communication
is number one absolutely everything you
read is how well can you communicate to
your team to your managers accepting
feedback telling your data story
something even deeper but thinking about
ways you've communicated in the past how
about being really detail-oriented
people that have gone from finance into
being a data analyst see it all the time
and I always laugh at that one because I
was in finance I think my detail
orientation probably wasn't that as
strong so that's why I went into
something way less detail so my detail
orientation only went so far that I was
never gonna work past that about
financial analyst position I don't think
but if that's something you were really
good at you can take that over to being
a data analyst and that really helps
obviously management manager people of
managing projects managing processes so
thinking about different things you've
managed in one role and how you can
translate that into another role and as
you think about these transferable
skills it's
come with a story right my story was how
I wasn't detail-oriented so that wasn't
the story I would probably take with me
but let's say with communication when I
worked in Asia I worked with a lot of
different people different cultures so
when I became a corporate trainer I
became very I was looks a lot easier for
me to walk into a room and quickly kind
of assess the people and figure out ok
business probably where I need to
position this this is how I should
communicate it because I got it I got
really used to knowing how to kind of
look at the room and figure out how to
communicate so that was something that I
brought with me so as you go through
this list in it you don't need one
pretty each but these are just ideas
think about how these have you've used
these different skills in your life
research is a huge one anytime that you
especially going into fields like AI
where there's a lot of research and
development happening talk about how you
approach research how you've been
successful problem solving kind of going
in there with research and different
aspects that maybe you've done that
things like prioritization self time
management any analytical skills that's
kind of going back a little into the
detail orientation showing that you've
had analytical skills and you have maybe
a more mathematical type of thinking for
financial modeling maybe going into data
modeling maybe even in sales maybe you
have that strong communication that
ability to connect with people that's
going to make you give you some skills
that a product manager or program
manager really needs maybe you've done
some training and mentoring so if you're
looking at I've worked with people who
have been Udacity mentors and then
they've gone into roles where training
up new staff and mentoring some younger
software engineers has been helpful and
then obviously you're certain tech
skills maybe you're taking certain
classes now to appear tech skills that
you've got other tech skills you've been
using that can definitely help you and I
heard a lot of Udacity students say you
know I
can code and you know X Y & Z so it's
pretty easy to pick up something know
which by the way I admire all of you so
much for being able to do that so and
again these well this will be going on
to YouTube so you can kind of look at
this later you can snapshot a picture of
it now but these are really I think a
nice little list of transferable skills
because I think that's the hardest thing
to assess in ourselves it's easy to say
oh I'm really good at Python and I'm I'm
a really great I've great written
communication those are things I know
I'm good at my my weakness is X but when
we think about those transferable skills
we really have to go a little deeper and
think about how to connect how that was
a great skill before and how we're going
to use it in the future
so then the self-assessment maybe genus
is the little Turk we can imagine
someone filling out and I just like to
visualize it like this see I am a little
detail-oriented I like to kind of fill
it out and see it and think about how
that's positioning me for that next job
that I want
so you research the job you looked
inward at yourself you've done that
self-assessment now we want to learn the
landscape I talk to a lot of people are
saying well I'm moving from software
engineer to self-driving cars but I
don't know like who's doing that like
what do I get a job with where do I go
and who do I talk to if you really want
to start wearing the landscape but I
want to go be a let's see if I want to
go I want a restaurant in my town well I
need to find out what's going on there
what other restaurants are there who's
running them what are people doing if I
want to go be a self-driving car
engineer I need to make sure I know
who's hiring what types of roles are
this you really need to start learning
that landscape follow influencers on
LinkedIn look at the top companies the
top and then find out who the leaders
are in these conversations read blogs
ask people in your Udacity career not
career channel that that could help but
in the Udacity hub like what blogs do
you like to follow about computer vision
this is area I want to go and find out
what other people read I try to collect
quite a few and I've got some lists of
different ones that I've come across
that people like but asking people in
your field is the best way obviously if
we've all heard of probably
informational interviews basically
talking to people in the field find out
who's working as a data analyst that you
know or a friend of a friend that you
can have some initial conversations
these informational interviews where
you're just I don't really love that
term because it sounds like you're
actually having an interview it's
essentially just saying hey can I have a
chat I want to learn about what you do
and I find that when people take this
approach send out 50 messages and
hopefully have five conversations they
feel so much more informed they've
learned that landscape they understand
like this is who's hiring this is where
people like to work this company pays
well this is fun to work out pays off
it's good you learn all those times fun
things this is the kind of innovation
that's happening over here
these the type people they look for and
then looking for meetups and events in
your area is always good
you
the next thing and I know we are getting
close to time but think about creating
your narrative and this is you've
thought about your strengths your gaps
your your transferable skills and now
you need to really think how do I have
to position this I need to write it out
I need to talk about it so these are
some questions to ask yourself as you
create this narrative and this narrative
is something that you want to create so
that you have your pitch so that you
have a strong cover letter that you have
a great about section on LinkedIn that
you have a great introduction in an
interview you've got this very solid
branding of yourself that comes across
in every conversation anything you write
anyone you reach out to you really start
to feel like this is how I've kind of
packaged myself and I've got a nice
little bow on it now and I can be
passing it out to everyone and I feel
very confident and consistent with my
message so some questions ask yourself
what motivated my transition
the person who said they're going from a
PhD into industry why why do you want to
do that what motivates you what makes
you think about it so as you think about
that know your motivation that kind of
helps form some of your story even if
it's not something that's actually
something you might say or write out
later but it does start to help you
think about it why am i interested in in
this new role or again knowing your
motivation knowing what why you went but
you're aiming for what are my biggest
strengths as I consider this role now
remember you've already got those
written down you figure that out already
you've got how do you tell that in their
story in your narrative what are my
transferable skills we've identified
those already so it's all coming
together in this nice package how have I
overcome the weaknesses and gaps now
some some weaknesses and gaps you might
have decided you know what I don't think
that's that important I think I've got
enough strength over here I'm not going
to worry about it too much but think
about if it is something that's a little
more important have you taken a class
maybe as you're talking about
transitioning from software engineer to
machine learning engineer you can say
you know I started dabbling in machine
learning
I took nano degree did these three
projects I'm feeling really strong about
it and I'm super excited to use it on
the job and the last question is just to
ask yourself why would someone want to
hire me for this role and a lot of times
in my presentation skills classes I ask
people why are you at the front of the
room why are you the one speaking
because there's always a reason and it's
usually because of the knowledge you
have the skills you can bring something
that you can share there's if you're
going to interview for a job and you
don't know why they want you then you
probably can't convince them that they
do want you so you need to believe it
you need to know why they should hire
you
so again this narrative is your mission
statement it's your cover letter it's
your branding it's your anywhere your
your your getting this across you want
to say it you want to write it you want
to rehearse it you need to believe it
most interviews especially that first
phone screen start with a self
introduction and in those 90 seconds
let's say are when a most recruiters
will decide those interviewers are going
to decide do I want to keep talking to
you are you someone I'm gonna come
forward you can kill it in the first 90
seconds and kill it in two meanings I'll
kill it you can like kill it awesome or
you can kill it and be out so make sure
you're killing it to be awesome and I
see the transformation on people when
they take the time to create this
message and say it write it rehearse it
believe it switch it up change it your
confidence builds with yourself and
you're telling that story you're
creating that narrative you're giving
your personal value proposition and you
come across as someone that they believe
in they have confidence in and they want
to put forward to the next round with
you
all right so ready to jump ship I know
sometimes it's a scary jump I wouldn't
do that jump I'm seeing in that picture
by
we're gonna open it up for some
questions but for now like just thinking
about next steps I want you to share
your narrative I want you to create it
work on it with a coach discuss it say
it out loud or your husband your wife
your friend your colleague you need to
say it out loud I know that makes people
feel uncomfortable at first but I have
people when they practice it on the
phone with a coach and they tweak it a
little they hear it out loud it just
gets better and better and better then
you're gonna start connecting with more
people you're going to network more
you're going to fight for jobs so those
are kind of the next steps that we can
talk about in other sessions with a
career coach and get you on your way
so thank you all very much I am now
going to stop sharing my slides and see
all of you and open it up for questions
anyone have any questions again I've
lost my chat box make sure it's up there
you can catch him copy anything yes I
hit him I must say but I just got a
quick question for the career coach does
it include resume review any questions
thank you all for coming if there are no
questions I will stay on here a couple
minutes chat to myself
see if anyone pops up question thank you
again all for attending I would like I
you know I'll ask you all a question
one thing we've been talking about
Udacity is maybe with so many people
working from home is to have just an ask
me anything live zoom meetings where we
all just kind of grab a cup of coffee
and talk and ask questions so
interests you please keep an eye out for
that if you think it's a good idea type
something in the chat box let me know
and okay so some I think some of you are
trying to talk I got these new fancy
headphones that are wireless I did not
buy the Apple because I'm afraid I'm
gonna lose them so maybe it's not fancy
enough and I think maybe I'm not hearing
what's happening so I apologize for that
so maybe you will have to type in your
questions my teenagers told me I was
looking very old-fashioned with my cords
but they keep on going out to some types
of investor the nice Apple one okay
nineteen I don't think I'm hearing you
I'm not really sure why so anyway you
all are the tech experts not me so I
don't have confidence I'm gonna fix it
in the next minute so I'm gonna read
your questions that are coming through
so is part of the career coaching a
resume review yes in a couple ways in
your career portal you will find career
projects and in that you can go you can
submit your resume for review there's a
whole tutorial best tips practices so
it's basically a little mini project
that you get all the advice create your
resume submit it for review from one of
our document reviewers and in that case
they're they're great and kind of having
a rubric and do you have everything you
need and only big errors kind of doing a
sanity check like that then with a code
which the person personal career coach
such as myself from the team of us you
can use give us your resume in advance
attach it to it when you make your
appointment send it sometimes people
sharing a Google Doc and just say I want
to review my resume and while we don't
write it we give you we can give because
we're having a conversation getting to
know you we can give you a lot of
different maybe more insight we can do
some polishing some tweaking we can talk
about the positions you're looking for
making sure that again you're bulking up
the most important strengths and maybe
areas that we want to consolidate or
trim down somewhere else
so we can give a little more personal
advice and we're happy to do that Lauren
thanks for your comments being says I
want to
which to a job in another country is
there a different approach for me you
know I think in terms of approach I
think a lot of what we did today is
really relevant I also think that
there's some things you can do as you
target other countries other cities one
of the biggest things I I tell people is
to try to find people in that let's say
you're moving from Chicago to Luxembourg
and I I know that I want to go to
Luxembourg the first thing I'm gonna do
is start finding Americans in Luxembourg
hopefully maybe someone I know or
someone that knows someone that I know
and try to get some connections start
talking to people so kind of taking that
learning the landscape and expanding it
to like really focusing on who can you
talk to enough city to start
understanding that landscape a little
better and make some connections what do
you think about teaching what do you
think about teaching does that interest
you the PS how you mean me teaching like
I'm not really sure um the name says ASU
s maybe if you can tell me a little bit
more about teaching what you're thinking
about there daniel said one question I
always struggle with is when they ask
you early in the process what salary
range I'm targeting I know I hate when
that happens
I don't want to price myself out and I
also want to get my foot in the door the
first position industry it's such a
struggle with this one because it like
exactly like you said you don't want to
lowball yourself that you don't want to
be out of way out either so I always
recommend first like taking it from a
may be more analytical approach like in
terms of I've researched based on my
research what I'm seeing in the market
those kind of comments and then tying it
to you so let's say they say what salary
would you expect saying something like
well based on my research or what I see
in the market I would expect salaries in
this range I think that could be a
really good starting place for us to
talk how does that sound to you so that
you're saying like this is kind of what
I'm hearing this is about where it is I
think
we can start our conversations there
does that sound good to you and it kind
of also then puts the ball in their
Court a little so that they can say oh
wow you're way higher than we ever
expected then you probably don't want
work there anyway if they jump and offer
you the job right then you know you live
on yourself no I'm just kidding
look maybe that's you know and I also
sometimes a thing to say too is you know
I think that I hope that you would it be
offering competitive salaries and like
what we see in the market right now is
around this number plus or minus so I
hope we can start our conversations
around that point so it shows that you
also know that it should be a
conversation Dana said ma would be great
good I don't know if like so that back
to the curve the resume reviews those
the people who review those are very
different from the coaches they're kind
of people scattered all over that you
never speak to them they just look at it
from a rubric kind of like creating a
piece paper and the career coaches we
talk about it we we review them with you
and give you some advice as well see
make sure I'm getting two other
questions so
- you know I think the question is
applying to other countries I think that
one thing we have to remember right now
and probably unfortunately for like the
next I would say at least three months I
think trying to move to another country
is gonna be really tough I think that
with everything happening with the virus
and the quarantines getting a job in
another country is probably going to be
harder than ever right now one thing you
could look at is remote work I think you
know as people are hiring having remote
workers is going to be something that
becomes more and more the norm so maybe
getting some work if you're in a country
especially that might have a lower cost
of salaries and people are offshoring
into that area then seeing if you could
get a job with an international company
our company that's offshoring that so
you're getting exposure to work for the
people in that country but maybe you're
not able to meet it okay someone asks
just is everything ok with people at
Udacity and and what's kind of happening
you know I work everyone's working
remote right now I'm actually in Chicago
most everyone else is out in the Bay
Area in San Francisco I think that I've
been talking to people I think a lot of
people are just like trying to figure
out like their own personal lives and
getting a family safe and making sure
that everyone is kind of in a good spot
so I will check in someone mentioned
that community I'm sure that they
haven't heard from I will definitely
check in on that I'm gonna take a
picture of my screen right now just make
sure I have it and have the group that's
asking so I will look into that for you
to get back to you how do you think
can role in remote work and where to
find companies there a lot a few
different sources and match maybe if you
could email me again I'll put my email
on here again I have a list of some
resources that people have used to find
remote work and it really one of the
things I do recommend as well as
depending on what country you're in if
you're in a country where there there is
a lot of offshoring and so for example I
was working with someone from Romania
recently and there there are some when I
say offshoring it's like so big an
American company might say oh we need
you know 25 software developers and
forgot hired this group this team in
Romania so if you can find those the
offshore companies that hire and form
those teams that's a great way to kind
of break into that field and see who's
who they're hiring and I'm putting my
email one more time and as if you
send me an email or two sorry that was
mad D sorry that the names are kind of
coming up not full on my screen if you
want those resources for some of the
remote work I can send you those sites
of human email me and ask for this
alright well I'll speak of which I think
I do have a career coaching session
coming up in just a couple minutes
definitely take advantage of these Kris
coaching sessions that you get again I
know a lot of us are going to be opening
more time on our calendars as other
things are canceled so keep checking
back if it's full and we'll really look
forward to talking to all of you and
hope everyone stays how can you stay
safe and help and pray that this virus
is gone soon alright have a wonderful
week happy Saint Patrick's Day and I'll
look forward to hopefully speaking with
many of you again soon hi I'm sorry I
couldn't hear you all I don't know how I
managed to do that
you
thank you bye